former Vice President Joe Biden says he
would do everything within his executive
power to make sure Americans wore masks
in public if he were elected president
the presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee is highlighting another contrast
between his thinking and that of
President Trump as Biden's poll numbers
surged especially in key battleground
states ed O'Keefe has the latest good
afternoon everyone he's not campaigning
much but it doesn't seem to matter Joe
Biden is leading President Trump in
several key battleground states poll
after poll after poll show Biden leads
in places like Georgia and North
Carolina even narrowly in ruby-red Texas
Biden is pulling ahead as voters
continue to disapprove of the
president's handling of the pandemic
amazingly he still not hasn't grasped
the most basic fact of this crisis to
fix the economy we have to get control
over the virus and his job isn't to
whine about it his job is to do
something about it to lead my team
continues to search for his running mate
CBS News has learned that one-on-one
interviews with potential VPS all of
them women are set to begin after July
4th meanwhile voters in Kentucky and New
York are still waiting for the results
of Democratic primaries held last
Tuesday official results aren't expected
until next week because a record wave of
absentee ballot requests caused by the
pandemic are still being counted when
results are announced it's likely a
group of younger minority and liberal
challengers will prevail over
well-funded incumbents and party
favorites in the New York area three
black men two of whom would be the first
openly gay black men in Congress are
poised to win primaries in predominantly
Democratic districts and in Kentucky
state representative Charles Booker is
leaving moderate Amy McGrath in the race
to take on Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell all four men surged in part
due to fresh support generated by
nationwide calls for police reform and
racial justice and ed O'Keefe joins us
now from Washington DC one ask it's
taking several days to determine who is
winning some of these primary races so I
think the question a lot of people are
asking is are we going to see this kind
of leg
after the general election in November
and if so what kind of issues arise out
of that we certainly could Jeff in
several states and it's because of the
crush of absentee or mailed in ballots
people who don't want to go stand in
line I'm at the pandemic for all the
reasons dr. agus was just discussing a
few minutes ago you know there's too
much risk so states most of them
encouraging people get your absentee
ballot and send it in the problem is it
takes a little longer to count those
paper ballots and so if it's a blowout
either way for the President or for
Biden it may matter less and it'd be
more like dotting eyes and crossing T's
but if it's a close race and we're
waiting for a handful of states to give
us the results it could lead to several
days or weeks of uncertainty and there's
big concern that both the president or
maybe even Biden would be raising doubts
about those results and cast into doubt
the winner of the election it's a
nightmare scenario but it's one we all
should be thinking about just another
example of how the pandemic really has
upended society
yeah some very interesting information
there itoki thank you very much